sad thing is that
it's one thing
to forget about color when you put on
your physics hat
it's in fact necessary that's how
physics are originates from that
blindness what is said is if you carry
that blindness over to your normal life
then you become a materialist and in a
sense you talk nonsense
and not only do you talk nonsense but
you can't recognize that this is
nonsense
and this is more or less where the
intellectual lead of the Western World
stands now
that they
take the physical Universe to be real
and the corporeal world is then what
Descartes called the riskogita the thing
of the Mind
and this is what Whitehead called
bifurcation and he spent maybe 30 years
of his life going around to all the
universities in Europe and America
trying to explain to the people how how
wrong this is how actually foolished but
the strange thing is that very few
people got the message
and in fact uh
anyone who tries to explain to a
physicist the idea of bifurcation will
to his disappointment learn that
the likelihood is 99.9
that the physicists won't understand the
word he's saying
because his bifurcationists
and therefore spurious metaphysics is so
ingrained in the mind of a physicist and
you know that's understandable because
you can't do physics until you buy for
kids
it is a bifurcation that in a sense
creates the physical universe and that's
what the physicist is there to
understand that's what he thinks about
morning noon at night
until he regains a normal State of Mind
when again the grass is green
but while he is doing physics the grass
is not green
why while he is doing Felix he is
bifurcationist
he's a Cartesian
and so he sees only a part of the world
and incidentally this is what makes the
whole Enterprise in a sense a wholesome
because man was not put here on Earth
to put on blinders
and actually
shut off the better half of the world
what the physicist casts out by his very
his very modus operandi
is in fact
the creme de La Creme I mean the the
World of Color and sound and all these
innumerable things that poets think
about I mean sing about and
artists spent this is all blocked out
as soon as you put on a physics hat this
no longer exists and what uh what the
tragedy is that many physicists did not
moved
after doing physics for
a good length of time they forget that
the so-called physical universe is not
is not the whole thing
and so in a sense they are split into I
mean the human part of the physicists is
always there I mean we breathe and we
feel pain and so on I'd even feel love
but
officially we are democritian we know
only atoms and the void it's a terrible
disease
and it's a disease which can infect not
not only individuals
it can
infect the whole society and this is
what I have been trying to express in
all my writings that we the modern
contemporary West are a sick Society you
just watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy